let's bring in the columnist for the
Tampa Bay Times our extrao tack on the
program I think I asked you last time
you're on how's morale how's morale
today in Tampa well Dan you know the
Bucs want to keep the party going I mean
Tom Brady got kicked out of a workout
the other day by Parks and Rec lady okay
so you know you got to have some muscle
coming in here so he's got the guy that
you know nobody wants to party more than
Rob Gronkowski and and they're excited
to have them they think he's going to
bring a lot to their football team I
think the fans are jacked up and you
know it's it just who's next right I
mean we're just alittle Minh yeah that's
what I think that's what I think they
should have a kind of a massing or Tampa
Bay Edition you know where you just a
guy gets up there it's Robert crap you
know you just you know I mean this is
crazy
I mean we're gonna see Matt Damon and
Mark Wahlberg and and Ben Affleck
hanging out at Saint Jeter's Berg I mean
this is nuts
how did Brady end up in this park and
who is he in the park with I don't know
how he ended up in a park I mean I would
think for goodness sakes they can find
you know some place that's not like a
municipal Tampa you know tree-lined
place but my understanding is that you
know he does want to find a place to
work out with some of his guys I would
think that would be indoors more than
outdoors but yeah it's just it's just
kind of kind of nuts the Tampa Mayor was
on with the st. Pete mayor and they're
having their talk about coronavirus and
she goes oh yeah by the way big family
this guy was you know working out and
one of our Parks and Rec lady came up
and it turned out to be Tom Brady so
yeah he got kicked out well when I heard
Tom Brady had been cited and then I said
wait a minute how do they spelling cited
is it with an S or a C yet isn't there
any room in the Jeter house that he
could work out of course there is I mean
his media room is you can hold a passing
camp in there are you kidding me the
things 30,000 square feet but yeah but I
guess he wanted some fresh air or
something it was it was just a weird
story and it wouldn't have happened in
Brookline I can tell you that you have
Gronk coming to town and I I'm
cautiously optimistic I still think this
is a playoff team I think they'll firm
up the offensive line maybe
they trade for Trent Williams but you
know they get the offensive line
situated now you got a legitimate
playoff team here I don't know what
Gronk's addition is going to mean and I
don't know what it means for the future
of OJ Howard
so can you fill us in with some of the
gray area there yeah I think what the
addition means is that you know for all
the antics that you see with Gronk off
the field I mean he's a seriously hard
worker right and and Brady when he came
here made the Bucks aware that Gronk
wanted to play here wanted to play again
wanted to play in Tampa with him you
know so he's got somebody he's familiar
with that that's important he's going to
help that room and right now it's a
crowded one right he mentioned oj Howard
now you know obviously if they get blown
away by an offer and I don't know what
that would be a second-round pick or
something like it they would consider
trading them they got a lot of tight
ends with Cam Brayton and some others
but right now you know unless something
happens that again in the next two days
I mean their plan is to go with a lot of
12 personnel we saw you know Brady do
that with Aaron Hernandez and Gronk up
there in New England they certainly
could could line up that way and they
think that OJ Howard who's you know he's
still in on his rookie contract so he's
a cheap he's a cheap guy right now and
and they don't have to make a decision
till man on the fifth-year option so
could he get traded yes it hasn't
happened yet I don't know what leverage
they really have everybody knows they
got a surplus of tight end so we'll know
we'll know pretty soon how our season
ticket sales whether we're through the
roof you know the big question is it you
know can people use them I mean you know
Ticketmaster is not refunding right now
so that's a problem but they had you
know the day they signed Brady they had
like an eight eight thousand waiting
list online just to just to be able to
order them so look they'll sell out that
building there's no doubt about that
this just ratchets it up even more and
you know but again here we are and you
know 100-year pandemic and no one really
knows if they do play where their fans
can actually go to the games or not so
that that part's more than unfortunate
of course there's bigger things going on
in the world than in football certainly
but but then you know they're excited I
mean how could you not be right can you
be objective and look at this team and
and and honestly look at them and say
what you it feels like the
like the Cleveland Browns last year
where they were way too hot and I said
this team is not a playoff - yeah you
know I can't be ejected don't getting
choked up not because of the question
but I can't be objective and I think you
know I had a couple coaches to tell me
the way they were described this team
was a below average but improving and so
you know that that's sobering right if
you're hearing that from inside the
building the you know some one person
told me we're not as good as everybody
else thinks we are but we're going to be
pretty good so you still got to do it on
the field I mean this guy's played in
the same for the same coach the same
system for 20 years and so there's going
to be adjustments right but they had a
young defense I mean they got some guys
back and free agency they resigned Shaq
Barrett and Gamakatsu
Corson Jason pierre-paul and the
secondary grew up so you know the
division is good you've got to beat New
Orleans New Orleans still has better
personnel New Orleans still has three
straight NFC championships and they
still got Drew Brees so I mean I until
you can take and knock those guys out
you're not even a favorite in my mind to
win the division what happens though
we're talking to Rick Stroud the
economist for the Tampa Bay Times what
happens though Rick is we in the media
we root for a story like oh yeah like I
was rooting for Brady to go someplace
else because it would give me content to
talk about Gronk coming back gives us
content draft coming all these things so
we're sort of rooting for Tampa do do
well as if we're gonna say to Bill
Belichick oh so you were the genius here
or you know we want to get back at the
evil empire the New England Patriots by
rooting for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and
I just feel like and I saw Vegas the
odds they went from the sixth best odds
to the fourth best odds to win the Super
Bowl nervous that makes me nervous here
yeah I mean history says you're not
going to super born your hometown right
so they've got that going against them
but but look it is it is fun it is a
good story you root for stories no one's
rooted hard for a story than me then
covering a team has got a three eight
seven career winning percentage so I
think that you know it is it is a good
story and look these are good football
players I mean if Brady no one's ever
done this before at 43 right but but he
still can throw and he still can play
it's not Peyton Manning you know coming
out of Indianapolis where he's all
broken down so let's see how it goes I
mean I think it could be fun they had a
decent football team last year there
were seven and seven to shoot I'm better
we know about the turnovers in Jameis
Winston Bruce Arians is a hell of a
coach I mean he didn't win those awards
and all those games by not knowing
football so I think it's worth you know
if you're a Bucks fan getting excited
about it or an NFL fan I don't think
it's going to be Michael Jordan with the
Wizards you know I think this is
something that that's legit it's good to
talk to you Rick would you rather have
Brady and Gronk or the city hosting the
Super Bowl Wow yeah I you know Super
Bowls have been here they're big events
man I think I'd rather see Brady and
grow now I get it that's that's probably
the right answer there but I'll let
Tampa you know go after you now because
you don't care about this city
Thank You Rick we appreciate your time
as always thanks that's Rick Stroud he
covers the Buccaneers in the NFL for the
Tampa Bay Times